on parle du secteur du bâtiment à
présent avec Daniel taravel le président
de la Fédération française du bâtiment
dans le département des ivelines bonsoir
à vous bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
étiez déjà venu le 29 janvier dernier
avec un message clair trop c'est trop
c'était même une opération nationale le
mot d'ordre d'une opération nationale
afin de sensibiliser les pouvoirs
publics élus ministres quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui 3 mois après
est-ce que l'opération trop c'est trop a
porté ses fruits alors effectivement
nous avons nous avons l'impression que
cette opération a effectivement porté
ses pruits puisque le président de la
République a annoncé un plan bâtiment et
que donc notre action à priori n'aurait
pas été inutile cela étant je dois tout
de même dire que au présent notre la
situation du bâtiment est toujours
difficile et catastrophique puisque je
rappellerai que nous sommes sur un
rythme de baisse d'activité de l'ordre
de 3 et5i% que nous allons perdre sur
2013 40000 emplois au plan national et
environ 1500 emplois sur le département
et et que pour disons pour concrétiser
un peu tout cela je dirais simplement
qu'au niveau national cela équivaut à un
plan PSA hnet tous les mois ce qui est
tout de même important et ce qui
pourrait peut-être marquer les esprits
alors qu'il est bien évident que dans le
bâtiment beaucoup de petites structures
donc les licenciements se font un petit
peu de façon diffuse et ne marquent pas
forcément les médias ça veut dire
peut-être aussi que les syndicats qui
opèrent dans ce secteur mobilisent pas
assez les troupes les personnes qui sont
concernées dans le bâtiment justement
pour se faire entendre parce que
effectivement on le voit bien dans les
médias ce sont C ces groupes où les
salariés se mobilisent manifestent qui
se font qui se font entendre et dont on
parle plus bah dieu sait pourtant que
nous nous intervenons souvent nous
essayons souvent d'intervenir auprès des
pouvoirs publics nous intervenons auprès
des élus enfin vous je je l'ai déjà
équéêt trop sage peut-être je ne sais
pas si je suis trop sage que je dis je
je réitère encore ce que j'ai dit la
dernière fois à savoir que malgré
nos demandes réitérées nous n'avons
toujours pas pu rencontrer sur notre
département des représentants de nos
gouvernements actuel donc Mo toujours le
cas aujourd'hui cela étant pour revenir
si vous voulez bien au au Plan Bâtiment
bon donc encore une fois il a le mérite
d'exister il y a quelques mesures que
l'on peut considérer effectivement comme
positive je voudrais simplement évoquer
la baisse de la TVA pour les logements
sociaux qui va certainement donner un
petit peu d'oxygène pour les entreprises
qui sont concernées par ce créneau
d'activité encore que dans notre
département ce n'est pas la majorité
puisque les logements sont réservés un
petit peu au major euh la prime de 1350
€ pour les améliorations énergétiques
qui va qui devrait normalement inciter
les particulier à entreprendre des
travaux de cette
nature il y a également l'auto
liquidation de la TVA qui devrait
permettre de lutter avec un peu plus
d'efficacité sur la concurrence
desloyales de certaines entreprises
malhonnêtes mais c'est toutes ces
mesures que que vous citez les trois
mesures que vous venez de citer on
pourra en mesurer l'effet à partir de
quand alors justement c'est là c'est là
où où le bas blesse c'est que tout cela
se sont aujourd'hui des annonces que
dans le meilleur des cas ell seront
traduites en acte courant 2014 que cela
fait long c'est-à-dire qu'on a
complètement occulté l'aspect urgence du
problème et que durant durant ce
temps-là ben n nos entreprises
continuent de péricliter et de mourir tu
fait un autre point une autre
proposition que vous aviez faite hein
d'ailleurs avec ce plan trop c'est trop
qu'on évoqué tout à l'heure c'était la
sortie du secteur du bâtiment du régime
des auto-entrepreneurs alors les choses
n'ont pas beaucoup évolué si ce n'est
que la ministre du Commerce sylvia Pinel
s'est plutôt porté en votre faveur elle
semble plutôt le soutenir ce C cette
décision et puis aujourd'hui il y a
aussi la présidente du meddeef Laurence
Pariso qui a qualifié ce régime
d'auto-entrepreneur d'invention génial
mais avec une demande d'adaptation pour
le secteur du bâtiment puisque ça
infligait selon elle une concurrence
totalement déloyale à vie que j'imagine
vous partagez on peut peut-être rappeler
en quoi c'est une concurrence déloyale
ce statut d'autrepreneur c'est c'est une
concurrence déloyale tout simplement
parce que euh les auto-entrepreneurs ne
supportent pas les mêmes charges que les
entreprises n'ont pas d'assurance
obligatoire enfin tout un tout un
contexte qui fait que leurs coûts sont
nettement inférieurs à ceux de de nos
entreprises de type artisanal donc elles
leur font une concurrence détoilale et
puis il y a aussi un autre élément qu'il
faut évoquer peut-être un mot un petit
peu couvert mais qui reste tout de même
une réalité c'est que
l'auto-entrepreneur est aussi source de
travail noir puisque chacun sait que
lorsque l'auto-entrepreneur atteint son
plafond bah bien évidemment ensuite il
continue avec des arrangements alors il
y a pas d'aut entrepreneur pour vous
répondre ce soir sur ce plateau je vous
laisse mettre de vos de vos accusations
en les concernant euh pour vous ce
statut d'auto-entrepreneur en tout cas
si se verrou sautait si finalement le
statut d'auto-entrepreneur ne
s'appliquait plus dans le bâtiment ça
pourrait en tout cas être un petit coup
de pousce aider votre profession bien
évidemment ça aiderait forcément les
entreprises les petites entreprises
entreprises les particuliers qui font
appel aux auto-entrepreneurs peut-être
parce qu'ils sont aussi moins chers
ferait pas forcément appel à d'autres
artisans il vont peut-être remettre à
demain pense que oui c'est effectivement
une possibilité cela étant je pense que
quand on envisage des travaux à un
moment ou un autre on les fait on
continue à faire le point sur la
situation actuelle du bâtiment
principalement dans le département des
ivelines 23 avril mardi prochain vous
allez réunir 23 personnalités du du
département dans vos locaux chînet le
maire du chînet notamment représentant
du député des iveline François de
maierre et encore plein d'autres
débailleurs sociaux aussi pourquoi ce ce
rendez-vous bien justement pour essayer
de d'évoquer et de cerner certaines
pistes en matière de travaux d'économie
d'énergie parce qu'on se rend compte que
les gens qui les les particuliers qui
souhaitent réaliser ce genre de travau
ne savent pas toujours où s'adresser et
les collègues collectivités local sont
un petit peu aussi dans dans le même cas
donc l'idée ce serait d'essayer de
développer une piste pour parvenir peu à
peu à ce que l'on appellerait un guichet
unique qui permettrait effectivement de
répondre à la
demande que l'on que que l'on sent de
toutes de toute évidence quelles sont
les actions possibles facilement qu'on
peut mettre en place rapidement ben les
actions c'est c'est un petit peu là où
le côté un petit peu négatif de de du
Plan Bâtiment que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure
2014 voilà mais justement donc pour nous
il y a une mesure que nous regrettons
vivement qu'elle n'ait pas été retenue
c'est tout simplement la baisse de la
TVA en matière de travaux d'entretien et
justement de rénovation énergétique
puisque je vous rappelle qu'elle était
de 5 et demi il y a un an et qu'elle va
passer à à 10 dans un an donc
c'est-à-dire que en une année en une
année et demi nous allons la le taux va
doubler et il est bien évident que si on
revenait à un taux de 5 % ou dans le
pire des cas si on maintenait le taux de
7 % il y aurait là une source d'activité
immédiate pour nos petites entreprises
j'aiévoqué tout à l'heure peut-être une
attitude de trossage de la part de la
Fédération du bâtiment ou alors en tout
cas des principaux acteurs vous pensez
peut-être durcir le ton vous faire
entendre mobiliser du d'une autre
manière puisque aujourd'hui le message
encore du mal à passer B écoutez je
pense que ce n'est pas dans notre
philosophie d'entreprendre des actions d
violente comme on en voit quelques-unes
en ce moment bon nous avons toujours eu
pour méthode d'essayer de négocier et et
je crois que nous allons nous en tenir
là ce qui ne ce qui ne veut pas dire
pour ça que nous baissons les armes et
que nous continuerons pas à essayer de
démarcher nos élus merci Daniel
Taravella la Fédération française du
bâtiment toujours attentive aux
évolutions dans ce secteur notamment à
l'évolution du statut
d'auto-entrepreneur on l'a évoqué
puisque vous souhaitez l'exclusion du
secteur du bâtiment de ce régime ce
serait un coup de pouce non négligeable
selon vous et assez rapide qui se ferait
ressentir sur le secteur du B